واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
يقول تعالى يا ايها الناس انا خلقناكم من
ذكر وانثى وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل لتعارفوا
ان اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم ان الله عليم
خبير
قوله تعالى
يا ايها الناس
يتناول الانس
والجن
في قول كثير من العلماء
ان كلمه الناس
فانه يشمل الجن
اما كلمه الانس او كلمه
الاناسي او كلمه اناس فانه للبشر اولاد
ادم
على كل حال هو خلاف بين العلماء
والجن يدخلون في هذا الخطاب
اما
يدخلون في نفس اللفظ بعموم اللفظ او
الجن
وجنس الجن يلحقون
بالانس في هذا اللفظ
الحاقن
فهذا النداء لهم ولا نه وكل نداء في
القران يا ايها الناس يا ايها الذين امنوا
الى اخره كلها للانس والجن
كما ان قوله تعالى يا ايها الناس يا ايها
الذين امنوا الى اخره فانه يدخل فيه
الذكور والاناث
وان كان
النساء لا تدخل في هذا الخطاب في عموم
اللفظ ولكن
لشمول العله والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول
النساء شقائق الرجال النساء شقائق الرجال
والامر اذا وجه للانسان فالاصل انه للذكور
والاناث الا ان يدل دليل على اخراج
احداهما كذلك
فهو للانس والجن كل ما يخاطب الله تعالى
به الانس من
الامر والنهي والوعد والوعيد وما شابه ذلك
فانه للانس وللجن لكن الله سبحانه وتعالى
وجه الخطاب الى الذكور
لان النساء
تبعات للذكور للرجال
ووجه
الخطاب لبني ادم
لان الرسل من بني ادم
والمنذرون
من الجن
الجن ليس منهم رسول ولا نبي بعد خلق ادم
عليه السلام هذا في قول الجمهور من
الجمهور العلماء
الله عز وجل
يقول في ابراهيم وجعلنا في ذريته النبوه
والكتاب
وفي نوح وابراهيم وجعلنا في ذريتهما
النبوه والكتاب سوره الحديد
وليس من ذريه
نوح عليه السلام ولا ابراهيم احد من الجن
فيما نعله
لكن الجن
تبع
للانس في هذا
طيب
هل كان من الجن رسل
قبل
خلق ادم عليه السلام
هذا كلام في خلاف بين العلماء والظاهر انه
كان نعم
انه كان في رسل من الجن وانه ارسلوا وهذا
على قول كثير من الصحابه رضي الله عنهم
وبهذا
فسر قول الله سبحانه وتعالى
يا معشر
الانس والجن الم ياتكم يا معشر الجن
والانس لم ياتكم رسل منكم يقصون عليكم
اياتي وينذرونكم لقاء يومكم هذا قالوا
هذا يدل على ان من الجن رسل بعض العلماء
ادخل هذا في ظاهر اللفظ وبعضهم قال هذا بل
هو فن من فنون اللغه العربيه على كل حال
يا ايها الناس نداء للانس نداء للجن نداء
للذكور نداء للاناث
خطاب للجميع لان الجن قبائل
والجن
يكون فيه ما يكون في بني ادم من الذنوب
مثل الفخر بالانساب والطعن في الانساب
وما تسمى
العنصريه
والظلم
والاعتداء في القول والعمل
والباغي والعدوان والشرك وما شابه ذلك كل
هذه جاريه في الجن كما انها
جاريه في في بني ادم يقول يا ايها الناس
انا خلقناكم من ذكرا وانثى
الله عز وجل خلق الانس
من ذكر وانثى وهم ادم وحواء
او ذكر وانثى يعني كل واحد منا
مخلوق من
الجنسين من ذكر ومن انثى
وكذلك الجن
يقول تعالى
وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل لتعارف ويعني
صراحه
مرات
ناس بيسالوك اسئله تحتار منها
يعني انا
عندهم
رقم الهاتف تبعي متداوله
بدي اتصل بك احد على الساعه 2:00 الصبح
وقال ملح
ايش يا اخوي
يقول لك الجن
مو طول ولا لا
يعني انت اتصلت علي على الساعه 2:00 الصبح
عشان تسالني اذا الجن بموت ولا لا لانه
انت مش قادر تنام لما انك تفهم اذا الجن
بموتو ولا بيعيشوا
وهلم جره
وبعدين اذا الشيخ زعل قال يا عم انت بتتصل
علي على الساعه 2:00 الصبح تسالني اذا
الجن بوالده
يقول لك الشيخ عصبي
الشيخ عصبي
فاستطرادا لان السؤال يتكرر كثيرا
هذه مساله شاعت بين الناس
مثلا
ان خلقناكم من ذكر وانثى هل ممكن
الجن والانس
يولده يعني ذكر من الانس وانثى من الجن او
العكس ممكن هذا الكلام ما في عليه دليل
قيل هذه الاشياء لكن منع هذا العلماء
والفقهاء
لانه اذا اردنا ان نقيم الحدود
جاء في الحديث
والقاعده المشهوره النادره الحدود
بالشبهات
يعني ممكن واحد
او وحده تاتي حامل وتقول لا انا زوجي من
الجن زوجه
ماذا نصنع شبهه
لذلك العلماء منعوا هذا خاصه في التقاضي
والحدود وهذا الكلام
ظاهر انه خرافه
يظهر لي وجود هذا الشيء لا في الواقع ولا
في كتب المتقدمين
مما يوثق فيه من الكلام وانما كلام يقال
يقال هكذا
هل من الممكن ان الجن يتدخل في الانس
الفعل
جن يقتل انسي او العكس نعم هذا ثابت في
القران وفي السنه
لكن
هذه الاشياء مما
حكاها الناس ويتناقلها الناس من انه امراه
في البلده الفلانيه حملت من شيطان وانه
رجل في البلد الفلاني عنده
نساء كثيره من الجنيات واشياء يعني تسمع
خرافات الناس لكن في كتب العلماء
نادر جدا تجد هذا الشيء واذا وجد فانه
ليس شيء
موجود ثابت معروف معهود عند العلماء شيء
نادر جدا وشيء لا يكاد يذكر
انا اذكر هذا
للمناسبه يعني من كان يظن انه هذه المساله
تطلع معنا في ان خلقناكم من ذاكره وانثى
لكن اقول تعالى يا ايها الناس انا خلقناكم
من ذكر وانثى وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل
لتعارفوا
الشعوب
والقبائل القبائل جمع قبيله وهي دون
شعوب والشعوب
جمع شعب
والعلماء رتبوا العرب يرتبون
القبائل
ويرتبون على الشعوب فهي فهي للعرب وللعجم
ان الله تعالى جعلهم
شعوبا وقبائل الشعب اوسع بكثير من القبيله
القبيله دون ذلك وهي المشهوره المعروفه
عند العرب لماذا جعل الله سبحانه وتعالى
الناس شعوبا وقبائل
يقول تعالى
لتعارفوا اللام هنا للتعليل
والتاء هذه اصلها
لتتعارفوا لكن اسقطت التاء
خفيفا
لتعارفوا والمقصود بالتعارف ان يعرف احدنا
نسب وان يعرفوا احد وان يعرفوا يعرف يعرف
احدنا
رحمه
فيقوم بصله الارحام
ويقوم
بتنظيم النسل بمعنى انه يدري هذا يحله ان
يتزوج او هذا لا يحله ان يتزوج منه يعني
من البيوت
فهذه هي الاسباب التي جعل الله سبحانه
وتعالى الناس شعوبا وقبائل
وهذا جاء في ماذا في الرد
وفي سياق الكلام
وفي القصص الموجوده في اسباب نزول هذه
الصوره وهذه الايه
ان
بني اسد
افتخروا على غيرهم وافتخروا وتفاخروا على
الفقراء من المهاجرين ممن ليسوا
من اصحاب الانساب العريقه مثل سلمان
الفارسي
وصهيب الرومي وغيره
فلما جاؤوا في عام الوفود الى رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
سنه التاسعه
وجدوا هؤلاء حول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وهم
يعني وهم لا نسب لهم وكثير منهم لا مال له
مثل اهل الصفه
كانهم ازدروا
هؤلاء
الاماجد من الصحابه فانزل الله يا ايها
الناس انا خلقناكم من ذكر وانثى وجعلناكم
شعوبا وقبائل لتعارفوا
ان اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم يعني ليس الا
للتعارف بس
هذا هو السبب الوحيد من اجل
معرفه النسب ومعرفه النسل وما شابه ذلك
هذا هو السبب الوحيد ان الله عز وجل جعلنا
في هذه الهيئه يقول تعالى واما بالنسبه
للكرامه يقول ان اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم
ليس صاحب النسب ولا صاحب الحسب وليس صاحب
المال والفخر وما شابه ذلك بين الناس
وانما الكرامه
هي في تقوى الله سبحانه وتعالى
فان اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم
وبهذا اجاب الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم جاء
في صحيح مسلم
ان احد الصحابه سائل النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم فقال من اكرم الناس
فقال اتقاهم
قال لا ليس عن هذا اسالك
قال فيوسف
نبي الله ابن نبي الله
ابن نبي الله
ابن نبي الله ابن خليل الله قال ليس عن
هذا اسالك
قال
عن معادن العرب تسالوني
معادنا العرب يعني
انساب العرب تسالوني
فهو اجاب على السؤال باعتبارات
اعتبار الاول
اجاب بالسؤال عن الفرد
من اكرم الناس يعني على
الافراد
بين الافراد افراد الناس
هل هو ذكر هل هو الانثى هل هو
هو اجاب بمعنى الايه بل بلفظ الايه وقال
اتقاهم
هذا
تضمينا
من
قول الله سبحانه وتعالى ان اكرمكم عند
الله يتقاكم فقال ليس عن هذا اسالك يعني
ليس عن هذا الاعتبار
فاجاب النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بالاجابه
الثانيه
باعتبار ماذا باعتبار
باعتبار النسب النسب يعني الناس من هو
اكرم الناس نسبا
فهو يقول يوسف
نبي الله
ابن نبي الله
ابن خليل الله
هذه القمه
فقال ليس عن هذا اسالك
ففهم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ان ان
السائل يسال عن ماذا يسال عن قبائل العرب
ما كنا نقوله
ونفاضل بين
القبائل قبل الاسلام هل منه شيء صحيح
كنا نقول بني فلان خير من بني فلان كنا
نقول
قريش اشرف الناس كنا نقول وكنا نقول فهل
من هذا شيء صحيح فقال هو
ليس عن هذا اسالك قال فان معادن العرب
تسالوني
يعني اسمع ماذا عبر النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم به قال عن معادن معدن
مثل الذهب مثل الفضه مثل هذه معادن الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول في حديث عائشه في
الصحيحين
الناس معادن كالذهب والفضه
خيارهم في الجاهليه خيارهم في الاسلام اذا
فقه
وبهذا اجاب النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فقال
عن معادن العرب تسالوني
قال
خيارهم في الجاهليه خيارهم في الاسلام اذا
فقيهوا
نفقه
لغه قريش اذا فقه بطم القاف
فالمقصود هنا
ان هذه الانساب انما تكون شريفه بماذا
بالتقوى
واما اذا كان فيها من الشرف بين الناس ما
كان فيها لكنهم على غير تقوى الله فان هذا
لا ينفعهم كيف هذا كيف نفهم هذا الكلام
الجواب
انه نقول مثلا لو انا سالتك
قلت من الانفع
الغني ولا الفقير
انا الانفع للناس
نقول الغني هو انفع بمعنى انه عنده
استطاعه ان ينفع غيره لكن بشرط ما هذا
الشرط
شرط ان
يتقي الله سبحانه وتعالى يكون مرزوق علم
وقدره على الانفاق فاذا عنده علم
فهذا خير الناس حالا عنده مال وعنده علم
ينفق هذا المال
ويسلطه الله سبحانه وتعالى على هلكته في
الحق هذا خير الاحوال صح ولا لا اذا كان
عنا احنا فقير لا مال له
وعنده علم وغني له مال ولاه علم
ايهما
افضل من ناحيه نفع الناس من ناحيه
الاستطاعه من ناحيه القدره نقول ماذا
الغني صح ولا لا لانه اقدر
لانه اقدر لكن هذا ليس كان نقول الغني خير
من الفقير لا ليس شرطا ممكن نقول جنس
الغني خير من جنس الفقير يعني من اجناس
الناس يعني
مثل ما اقول
المبصر خير من من الضرير
يعني المبصر خير من الضرير
يعني المبصر الذي يستطيع ان يبصر خير من
الذي لا يبصر لكن هذا ليس على الافراد هذا
من ناحيه ايش الجنس يعني جنس المبصر خير
من جنس
الضرير لكن ليس الافراد ليس معنى كل مبصر
خير من كل
طريق هذا غلط لانه فيه من
فيه من الناس يكون ضريغا وهو خير واحسن
واقوم عند الله واكرم عند الله سبحانه
وتعالى بل وانفع من ملء الارض من المبصرين
وهلم جر
فهذه الانساب
هذا الخير الذي توارثه او توارثته هذه
القبائل كل قبيله رثم
ترث الكرامه والخير والاداب والمال
والاشياء هذه تتوارثها
هذه تجعل هذه القبائل كالمعادن
هذه المعادن خير
بشرط
ان تكون
تقيه لله سبحانه وتعالى
نفس الشيء لو انا اقول لك مثلا الذهب خير
من الفضه صح ولا لا ذهب خير من الفضه لكن
هل كل ما هو مصوغ من الذهب خير من كل ما
هو مصوغ من الفضه لا
الان اشياء اخرى تدخل في المساله ليس فقط
المعدن ننظر اليه الان الان ننظر الى
الصيغه وننظر الى اشياء كثيره مهاره
الصائغ والى اخره
حتى يخرج لنا شيئا
شيئا
مجهزا يعني واصوخ
فابليس ماذا قال قال انا خير منه خلقتني
من نار وخلقته من طين
هذا كلام باطل صح ولا لا
اول شيء
فيه تفضيل النار على الطين وهذا فيه نظر
الرد عليه كثير من العلماء
والشيء الثاني
ان الفضل في الافراد لا يكون في المعدن
فحسب صح ولا لا
يعني مثلا الانسان من تراب الانسان من
تراب هل معناه انه الانسان تراب
رجل جواب
يعني الجن من النار هل معناه ان الجن نار
بعض الناس يسال السؤال كما اسال كثير عن
الجنه بتجيني بعرفش ليش بقول لك مثلا كيف
كيف ربنا يعذب الجن في النار وهم النار من
نار مش نار هم
في فرق صح ولا لا
يعني الجن من اصله من النار مش معناه انه
ما زال نارا تحول وتغير وربنا سبحانه
وتعالى اعتنى به
واعطاه روح واعطاه وفعل وفعل وفعل وجعل له
حدودا في الوجود
الى غير ذلك
فالمعدن وحده لا يكفي في التفضيل
لا يكفي
قوله خلقتني من نار وخلقت ومن طين حتى لو
كان هذا الكلام صحيحا
فان هذا ليس
مفاضله بين
الطين والنار هذه مفاضله بين ادم وغيره
فرق
لماذا
لان هذا اعتنى الله به اكثر من هذا
هذا خلقه الله سبحانه وتعالى بيديه ونفخ
فيه من روحه
واسجد له الملائكه ولم يفعل ذلك بذكر وهذا
فضل الله يؤته من يشاء
فهذه العنايه الا تدل على تفضيل تدل على
تفضيل صح ولا لا يعني ان اعتنى الله
سبحانه وتعالى
بالانس
وجعلهم
فيما جعلهم فيه
ولقد كرمنا بني ادم وحملناهم في البر
والبحر ورزقناه من الطيبات وفضلناهم هذا
لا يدل على
المفاضله للانس على الجن نعم
الانس خير
الانس خير من الجن لكن هذا في الجنس ليس
في الافراد مش معناه انه كل انسي خير من
كل جني هذا غلط ممكن يكون فيه افراد من
الجن خير من كثير من جماعات من الانس
وهكذا واحنا ذكرنا هذا فيما سبق ارجوا ان
تفهم هذه المسائل لانها مسائل مهمه بعض
الناس يخلط بين
ما يسمى عند الناس بالعنصريه
وما هو
تفضيل من الله سبحانه وتعالى فيه بعض
الاحوال يعني النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
اذا قرات هنا يقول ان اكرمكم عند الله
يتقاكم ثم يقرا قول النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ويقول فبعثت فيه خير الناس من خير الناس
تقرا في قول الله تعالى
رسول من انفاسهم رسول من انفسكم ماشي في
بعض القراءات فانت تقول كيف هذا يعني
كيف التوفيق التوفيق ان
على سبيل الافراد الذي يهمنا التقوى
لكن لو وجد مثلا
مقارنه
نقول هذا
هذا مسلم
امن بالله ورسوله
وقام بنفس الاعداء التي قام بها هذا
نفس الشيء بالضبط حتى هذا لم يفطل هذا
بتسبيحه واحده نفس الشيء بالضبط
في فرق واحد لكن ايش هو الفرق
هذا
لقي النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم مؤمنا به
وما تعلى ذلك الايمان وهذا لم يلقوا ايهما
افضل
هذا لانه صحابي صح عليه تعريف الصحابي
طيب انا ما عندي استطيع انا ادرك الصحابي
لو عندي فرصه اكون صحابي بكون اقول ذلك
فضل الله ياتيه من يشاء هل انقصك من اجرك
شيء
لا ما انقصني من اجره شيء لكن فهذا فضل
الله نفس الشيء لما الفقراء جاءوا الى
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وقالوا ذهب اهل
الدثور بالاجور
يصومون كما نصوم ويصلون كما نصلي
ويتصدقون من اموالهم ولا مال لنا تصدقوا
به فقال الا ادلكم على شيء اذا فعلتموه
لا يعني تبلغون من الاجر ما لا يبلغوا الا
من فعل مثله
سبحون الله
والى اخره الحديث معروف التسبيح والتحميد
وتكبير بعد الصلوات
الفقراء فرحوا
فعلوا ذلك
فما لبثوا الا
وقد علم الاغنياء بها
فاخذوها منهم بعض
ماشي تعلموها وفعلوها فجاءوا
الى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وقالوا
وهم الان يسبحون كما نسبح فقال ذلك فضل
الله
يؤتيه من يشاء
مش ممكن احنا نخلي المساواه في كل شيء لا
في ناس اختارهم الله ناس وفقهم الله
توفيقا اكثر من غيرهم وهذا يعود الى حكمه
الله ولا علم الله سبحانه وتعالى
والله عز وجل وصف نفسه
بالخيار فقال سبحانه وتعالى
وربك يخلق ما يشاء
ويختار ما كان لهم الخيره
هذا في ماذا
في اختيار من يكون نبيا يعني قريش قالوا
ليش هو ليش ما هو رجل من القريتين عظيم
فقال
ربك يخلق ما يشاء ويختار ما كان لهم
الخيره الله اعلم حيث يجعل رسالته
فلو قلنا هذا وهذا
نفس العمل لكن هذا له حال من التوفيق وقسط
من التوفيق تجعله فاضلا على هذا هذا يكون
يعود الى ماذا الى فضل الله
ومنه قوله تعالى والله فضل بعضكم على بعض
قال في الرزق لكن في جميع الاحوال والنبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم في جامعه الترمذي ذكر
ان
ادم عليه السلام لما خلقه الله
فانه لما خلق الله ادم فانه
اخرج له ذريته كامثال الذر فراهم وراى
منهم الاعرج والاعمى
فقال
لما لم تسوي بينهم يعني سال الله سبحانه
وتعالى
لما لم تسوي بينهم فقال اني احب ان اشكر
اني احب ان اشكر لو كل الناس نفس الشيء
بالضبط
اين يكون الشكر لا نفهم اصلا ما معنى
الشكر
لان الشكر لا يتبين الا بضده صح ولا لا
حتى نعلم هذا كفرا نعلم هذا شكرا وهكذا
الله عز وجل له الخيره ولا هو ان يخلق ما
يشاء وان يفعل بهذا الخلق ما يشاء وثم
اشياء لابد ان يسلم لها الناس
ممكن يقول الانسان انا فقير لماذا لم اجعل
غنيا
الله عز وجل
جعل الامور هكذا الله فضل بعضكم على بعض
في الرزق مهما
تفعل في بعض ناس مهما يعملوا
لن يزالوا فقراء خلاص
كاتب الله عليهم هذا
وبعض الناس مهما كانوا كسالى ومبذرين
ومسرفين لا يزالوا اغنياء كتب الله عليهم
هذا لا ياتون على نهايه هذا المال
ماذا نصنع هذا امر الله سبحانه وتعالى
وجعل بعضكم لبعض فتنه اتصبرون هذا يعود
الى الله
سبحانه وتعالى
فهذا هو المضمار الذي ينبغي ان تفهم فيه
هذه الايه هذه ايه مهمه جدا يكثر
الزلل في فهمها وبذلك يقول علماؤنا والله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد